juste une chose par rapport à ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure faut savoir
que quand on laisse michel fourniret en
miettes en train de pleurer et de boîtes
et pour rentrer dans sa cellule
s'il ne nous dit mains pour voir et là
je me tourne vers selim à ce moment là
j'ai dit mais tu lui dis pas au revoir
c'est sans doute la dernière fois tu
t'habitues loi et il a cette réponse
terrible mais justifiée il me répond
qu'il crève
moi j'avais perdu ma ceinture aux
portiques de sécurité parce qu'on doit
se dépouiller comme à l'aéroport
à ce moment là je panique chez ma
ceinture ma ceinture il dit qu'il se
pende avec ils comptent pas le revoir et
comparé prendre de ses nouvelles c'est
pour lui c'est vraiment un chapitre
tourner aujourd'hui ses limites une vie
mais une ville magnifique
en semaine tous parfois d'avoir des
petits tracas moi même j'ai un ami qui
s'est suicidée lui-même aurait pu passer
à l'acte il n'a pas fait s'est battu il
s'est construit aujourd'hui céline à une
vie magnifique il ya vraiment un message
d'espoir à travers sa reconstruction qui
est fabuleuse et oui c'est passé par la
vengeance mais elle a vraiment aidés
mais il y à un point que nous n'avons
pas mentionné parce qu'en fait
malheureusement on croit avoir évoqué le
pire on n'a pas évoqué le pire vous avez
appris un jour que vous aviez évidemment
quand j'étais tout petit servi d'appât
pour le rapt d'une des jeunes filles
c'est dur à vivre c'est on se sent
coupable
je sais que j'ai rien à voir là dedans
non mais bien sûr c'était dur me dire
c'est à cause de moi que cette fille
était pas à cause de vous non c'est pas
là et vous n'êtes pas responsables mais
chokolo vous êtes vous êtes victime
s'est pas de votre faute en fait c'est
difficile à entendre mais ce n'est pas
de votre faute
oui ça le sait le savoir elle accepter
c'est différent c'est que j'avais quand
même un sentiment de culpabilité
c'est c'est moi qui était bébé c'est moi
qui ait servi d'appât c'est a été mise
en confiance par mois il faut savoir que
quand michel fourniret projette de
kidnapper marie ascension c'était après
la réception d'un mauvais bulletin de
notes de selim il lui arrache son bureau
il le charge dans un camion il est
gilles lui dit et en a le plus besoin
c'est un cancre je vais aller le vendre
c'est durant ce trajet là qu'il croise
marie ascension encore une fois si
céline qui endosse la responsabilité
dans cette histoire à tort évidemment